Secretary of State Mike Pompeo is
calling on the international community
to step up pressure on Iran until it
stops what he calls its destabilizing
behavior the White House is trying to
form an international military coalition
to protect commercial shipping in the
Strait of Hormuz after several oil
tanker attacks blamed on Iran MTS tyub
is the only US network correspondent to
gain access to irani and control water
since tensions rose there recently he
reports now from a boat in the Strait of
Hormuz good morning well after a lot of
negotiations with the Iranian
authorities we were given access to
their territorial waters now right now
we're on a fishing boat it's a pretty
beautiful day out and the waters are
pretty calm here but make no mistake
this is perhaps one of the most volatile
areas in the world it's also one of the
most important every single day 1.3
billion dollars worth of crude oil
transits through here that's around a
third of the world's supply and because
of those tensions that we've been seeing
over the last several months President
Trump has ordered the creation of an
international maritime force to protect
those tankers that transit through these
waters
so far only Great Britain has agreed to
take part but in the last few days
Israel has volunteered something Iran's
chief of Navy has said could lead to an
all-out war for CBS this morning in
Pia's taya in the Strait of Hormuz Iran